to learn their secrets for moving those massive stones.
And as it turns out, Cyclops aren't even that strong.
They're just really smart about getting material to work for them.
Now, the videos you see behind me of large, stone-like, wobbly creatures
are the results of this collaboration.
OK, so Cyclops might be a mythical creature,
but those wonders are still real.
People made them.
But they also made the myths that surround them,
and when it comes to wonders, there's this thick connective tissue
between mythology and reality.
Take Easter Island, for example.
When the Dutch explorers first encountered the island,
they asked the people of Rapa Nui
how their ancestors could have possibly moved those massive statues.
And the Rapa Nui said,
"Our ancestors didn't move the statues,
because the statues walked themselves."
For centuries, this was dismissed, but actually it's true.
The statues, known as moai, were transported standing,
pivoting from side to side.
OK?
As spectacular as the moai are for visitors today,
you have to imagine being there then,
with colossal moai marching around the island.
Because the real memorial was not the objects themselves,
it was the cultural ritual of bringing a stone to life.
So as an architect, I've been chasing that dream.
How can we shift our idea of construction to accommodate that mythical side?
So what I've been doing is challenging myself
with putting on a series of performances
of the ancient but pretty straightforward task
of just moving and standing big heavy objects,
like this 16-foot-tall megalith designed to walk across land
and stand vertically;
or this 4,000-pound behemoth that springs itself to life
to dance onstage.
And what I've found is that by thinking of architecture
not as an end product but as a performance
from conception to completion,
we end up rediscovering some really smart ways to build things today.
You know, so much of the discussion surrounding our future
focuses on technology, efficiency and speed.
But if I've learned anything from Cyclops,
it's that wonders can be smart, spectacular
and sustainable --
because of their mass and their mystery.
And while people still want to know how those ancient wonders were built,
I've been asking Cyclops how to create the mystery
that compels people to ask that very question.
Because in an era where we design buildings
to last 30, maybe 60 years,
I would love to learn how to create something
that could entertain for an eternity.
Thank you.
(Applause)